tu es vraiment la copine de Guillaume ça
tu l'as dit aussi
parce que Guillaume là c'est amusé à le
dire et que à un moment donné tous ses
copains venaient me voir pour voilà me
répéter ce qui m'avait dit donc je me
suis dit allez hop vous êtes resté
combien de temps Guillaume et toi
ensemble je sais plus on s'est vu
quelquefois plusieurs fois quoi mais
ouais
un couple quoi cette galoche quand même
plus que ça Benjamin
il était jeune on était jeune voilà mais
vous avez fait plus avec Guillaume ou
avec Aurore
c'est un vrai une vraie aventure pour de
vrai
sympa c'était il y a longtemps il y a
quelques années 6 ans ouais au moins 7
ans je sais plus faudra lui demander ce
que lui il est plus elle est sur les
dates vous avez plus marqué que vous il
vous a marqué c'est ça
je ne sais pas